leur récréation par exemple c'est pareil
des fois par exemple moi je m'en vais
chercher un livre CDI lui les dehors en
train de le faire
demain on vous propose la lune d'entre
vous de faire un voyage un beau voyage
mais il y a de la basque pour une
personne comme on accepte
ah bon moi aussi
[Musique]
surprise pour sa réponse
je pense que vous auriez souhaité dans
des classes différentes
[Musique]
on a toujours été ensemble une habitude
avant et maintenant devant séparer comme
ça non c'est pas possible je dépends de
ma sœur comment elle dépend de moi les
récréations par exemple c'est pareil
des fois
par exemple moi je m'en vais chercher un
livre CDI lui il est dehors en train de
le chercher
de chercher
ton frère tu es mal sans lui oui
[Musique]
il y a des profs qui vont même jusqu'à
ne citer qu'un nom
au lieu de faire l'appel pour deux noms
ils font l'appel pour un non alors des
moments je m'énerve je dis bon ben je
sors comme ça il en restera plus qu'une
quoi c'est énervant c'est vrai là à ce
niveau là c'est stressant est-ce que
vous avez les mêmes caractères
et plus doux plus doux
j'essaie d'éviter de crier crier c'est à
dire ta mauvais caractère
c'est bien ça
une journée ou quoi on arrive pas ou
quoi c'était plus fort que nous il faut
que toutes les deux réussissent le bac à
la fin de l'année
qui réussissent pas en plus que c'est
moi qui a le plus mauvaise moyenne
on s'est toujours dit si jamais elle
redoute ça a terminal ou moi je redouble
et que l'autre elles sont bac
en tout cas moi je redoublerai en même
temps
psychologiquement elle ce serait trop
dur de savoir que moi je fais autre
chose que que je vis d'autre chose et
parce que je sais de quoi elle a besoin
et elle sait de quoi j'ai besoin pour
continuer
je pense pas être influencé par son
choix je veux dire le choix c'est c'est
moi qui le fais
bon il choisit de préparer telle classe
après le bac
moi c'est indépendant de ma volonté et
mon choix se fera pas en fonction du
chien quoi il faut penser à l'avenir
et c'est ça
cette pause question ça des fois je
pense quand même
et comment tu envisages les choses
bien on sait pas vraiment peut-être
qu'on montre notre petite entreprise à
deux
ce serait pas plus mal ça il faut encore
avoir les fonds et tout c'est pas
évident mais ça te plairait bien comme
projet d'avoir un projet commun ouais ça
serait bien non parce que toute façon on
va pas se marier ensemble alors
[Musique]